combinaison flotteurs palme brigitte
c'est qui cette compétition pour elle
c'est une grande première
alors à quelques minutes du départ la
tension un petit peu stressé la boule au
ventre
pressé d'être arrivé et heureuse de
participer à cette course
une centaine de personnes rejoint la
berge hommes femmes de tous âges mais
aussi de tous niveaux des derniers échos
des plus vieux
cécile elle est une habituée bi
championne de france de nage en eau vive
elle pense déjà tactique à palmer
avancés voire sont les concurrentes et
jouer stratégie quoi oh oh
c'est parti pour neuf kilomètres de
course
les compétiteurs descend de la loire un
niveau d'eau élevé un courant porteur il
quitte chessy et direction orléans
tractations sur la ligne d'arrivée
c'est la tante les premiers mètres 52
minutes dans le peloton de tête c'est si
c'est la première femme elle est 6e au
classement
je pense qu'il ya eu le mental et je
connais bien la rivière et je pense que
il physique elle physique a bien joué
aujourd'hui quand il faudra attendre
plus longtemps pour apercevoir brigitte
un peu déçu de sa course départ un petit
peu difficile on a le droit aux palmes
des autres et puis au judo essayé de
suivre c'est beaucoup plus difficile
derrière il y avait du compétiteur il ya
du haut niveau qui était parmi nous
aujourd'hui
c'était une très belle course avec un
soleil splendide magnifique c'était très
agréable
cette cour
pour être qualifié pour le championnat
de france il fallait franchir la ligne
d'arrivée en moins d'une heure c'est
chose faite pour nos deux nageuses
rendez vous donc à l'étape suivante en
juin prochain
hello